se vi chiedessi di rinunciare
volontariamente ad uno dei vostri sensi
a quale senso rinuncereste rinuncereste
alla vista all'udito al tatto il gusto
all'olfatto
a giudicare dalle risposte di più di
cinquemila persone che hanno partecipato
ad un sondaggio online
capiamo che più del 50 per cento delle
persone rinuncerebbe volentieri
all'olfatto
ed è per questo che ho cominciato a
chiamare questo senso un po di tempo fa
il senso cenerentola un senso che non
viene tanto considerato facciamo finta
di niente non capiamo
qual è la sua utilità però in realtà ha
delle funzioni che sono estremamente
importanti e ce ne accorgiamo in
particolar modo quando parliamo con le
persone cosiddette anomiche ovvero
coloro i quali hanno completamente perso
la capacità di percepire gli odori
vedete questo piatto di pasta pensate al
profumo che può avere
eccolo il fatto è un senso che influenza
il nostro appetito e che ci permette di
apprezzare i cibi e se pensiamo che
possiamo gustare questo piatto di pasta
fondamentalmente attraverso il senso e
il senso del gusto ci sbagliamo
pensate a quando avete il raffreddore il
naso tappato riusciti a sentire se un
cibo e dolce e salato ma vi perdete
tutte le sfumature perdete la sfumatura
del sapido che proviene dal parmigiano
oppure dal sugo di carne come facciamo a
capirlo il fatto ci da questo tipo di
informazione
inoltre è un senso che funge dal sistema
di allarme
questo sistema di allarme ci permette di
associare all'idea di odori sgradevoli
il fatto che possono essere indicatori
di patogeni o di possibili malattie per
cui siccome lo il fatto è un senso che
funziona a distanza quello che fa è che
ci allerta ci suggerisce di allontanarci
per evitare qualsiasi tipo di contagio
ma tra le funzioni dell'olfatto quella
che mi appassiona di più è il fatto che
contribuisca a creare ea mantenere le
relazioni interpersonali
infatti se noi pensiamo alle
informazioni che possiamo decodificare a
partire dal sudore delle persone
sono sicura che rimarreste sorpresi
possiamo riconoscere a grandi linee
all'età di un donatore possiamo
riconoscere il suo sesso
l'orientamento sessuale il fatto che una
donna sia in una certa fase mestruale
eppure se l'odore proviene da una
persona che ha un legame di parentela
con noi e se questo vi sembra già
abbastanza fantascientifico
tenetevi forti perché siamo anche in
grado di percepire dal sudore se una
persona è felice è disgustata
oppure è impaurita e quindi vedete che
sono da questo elenco
capiamo quanto il naso sia una macchina
molto fine per monitorare che cosa
accade nel nostro mondo sociale
circostante e se ad una domanda diretta
ecco questo è il sudore di una persona
felice non siamo poi così bravi a dare
una risposta accurata attraverso lo
studio dei comportamenti delle reazioni
psicofisiologiche dell'attività
cerebrale
siamo in grado di svelare qual è il
contributo dell'olfatto alle relazioni
sociali e questo mi interessa moltissimo
soprattutto perché vorrei capire come
questo senso può contribuire e
influenzare le relazioni interpersonali
soprattutto per i gruppi di persone che
hanno delle difficoltà in questo ambito
per questo ho cominciato ad occuparmi di
autismo che è un disturbo del
neurosviluppo che si caratterizza per
delle difficoltà di comunicazione e nel
comportamento sociale quando andiamo a
studiare il sistema olfattivo nelle
persone a sviluppo tipico la maggior
parte delle persone
troviamo almeno quattro buone ragioni
per andare a vedere come questo senso
funzioni nell'autismo in primo luogo
vediamo che ci sono poche connessioni
che uniscono la periferia del sistema
olfattivo alle aree centrali vedete sono
solo tre come i pallini rossi
batte la visione nettamente abbiamo
bisogno almeno del doppio delle
connessioni per processare
dell'informazione visiva in un cervello
come quello autistico in cui le
connessioni spesso si aggrovigliano tra
di loro questo potrebbe essere un grande
vantaggio
in secondo luogo il sistema olfattivo si
trova strettamente legato alle aree del
sistema limbico che a quel sistema a
livello neurale che si occupa di
elaborare le emozioni e la memoria il
sistema limbico ha un funzionamento
piuttosto anomalo nell'autismo malo il
fatto può essere un senso interessante
un modo alternativo per valutare il
funzionamento di questo sistema
in terzo luogo
vediamo come il sistema olfattivo non
sia legato al sistema linguistico a
livello cerebrale
se pensate anche alla vostra esperienza
e molto difficile nominare degli odori
anche molto semplice se non andiamo a
vedere qual è la fonte di quell'odore
questo ci permette di aggirare un altro
dei problemi che frequentemente vengono
riscontrati nelle persone con autismo
ovvero delle difficoltà di linguaggio
in quarto luogo sudare non richiede
tanta energia e nemmeno percepire un
odore
se c'è una fonte di un odore vicino a
noi e noi siamo vivi e stiamo respirando
ecco che ha molto probabile che noi
andremo a elaborare quello d'ora il
nostro sistema olfattivo verrà attivato
per cui questo ci permette non solo di
includere nelle ricerche sperimentali
delle persone che sono in grado di
seguire delle istruzioni talvolta anche
piuttosto complesse ma ci permette di
ampliare la ricerca a tutte le fasi
dello spettro e quindi di includere più
persone studio mettendo a frutto
tutte queste informazioni e cercando di
legarle insieme qualche anno fa in
collaborazione con l'università di
padova
abbiamo cercato un comportamento sociale
da inserire in un compito sperimentale
questo comportamento doveva suscitare
una prestazione piuttosto basta nei
bambini con autismo
naturalmente abbiamo poi inserito degli
odori per vedere se in qualche modo
riuscivamo a modulare la prestazione di
base questo compito è un compito molto
semplice si chiama di imitazione
automatica
immaginate un tavolo e ci sono due
persone sedute ai lati del tavolo un
modello e un bambino in mezzo abbiamo
posizionato un bicchiere
il compito del modello è quello di
raggiungere il bicchiere afferrarlo
alzarlo riposizionarlo e tornare alla
posizione di partenza
il modello compie questa azione solo nel
50 per cento dei casi mentre al bambino
la persona che sta dall'altra parte del
tavolo viene richiesto di compiere
questa azione in tutte le prove
quello che succede nei bambini a
sviluppo tipico è che sono più rapidi a
iniziare ea completare questa azione
dopo aver visto il modello eseguire la
stessa azione il nostro sistema motorio
praticamente pressi mula quell'azione e
ci permette di essere pronti ad agire ma
nell'autismo questa pre simulazione non
segue le stesse regole
la chiave di volta però avviene quando
inseriamo gli odori
se noi facciamo sentire l'odore della
propria mamma non l'odore di una mamma
qualunque ma l'odore della propria mamma
di un bambino autistico prima di
osservare l'azione ecco che la
prestazione di questo bambino
raggiungerà i livelli di prestazione
tipica abbiamo ipotizzato che questo
meccanismo sia mediato dal fatto che
l'odore della mamma e un odore
estremamente familiare è un odore
associato a cose positive
il che per questo renda più salienti le
informazioni visive
in ogni caso quello che abbiamo diciamo
concluso da questa ricerca è il fatto
che gli odori delle persone e di alcune
persone in particolari in caso di
bisogno
riescono ad essere degli ottimi
motivatori sociali ci sono anche dei
casi in cui però il l'odore delle
persone non aiuta le persone con autismo
in questo caso vi presenterò lo studio
di un gruppo di scienziati israeliani
del weizmann institute che hanno cercato
di capire come l'odore della paura
influenza adulti con autismo ma prima di
tutto mi fermo un secondo e vi parlo di
come raccogliamo l'odore della paura
perché può essere una cosa interessante
nel caso specifico di questo studio i
ricercatori hanno chiesto a dei donatori
di mettere una maglietta e poi li hanno
mandati a fare la loro prima sessione di
paracadutismo
potete immaginare che un po di paura
l'hanno provata generalmente però in
laboratorio non usiamo sempre queste
procedure strane quello che facciamo
generalmente a chiedere ai donatori di
venire in laboratorio gli facciamo
sempre mettere una maglietta e gli
facciamo vedere per una ventina di
minuti o più un video pauroso del
calibro di shining
potete anche voi facilmente immaginare
come vi sentite cominciate a sentire un
po di paura alle mani cominciano a
sudare ecco alla fine di questa
presentazione standardizzata del video
andiamo a ricevere la maglietta tagliamo
la parte sotto le ascelle la mettiamo in
un vasetto di vetro che faremo poi
annusare a qualcun altro che chiamiamo
recipiente e questo recipiente nel caso
dello studio degli scienziati israeliani
erano appunto come vi ho detto prima
degli adulti con autismo che cosa
succede per misurare se l'odore della
paura induce in noi una reazione
automatica di paura
andiamo a misurare la condotta nhtsa
cutanee come dicevo prima quando abbiamo
paura c sudano le mani quando le mani ci
sudano la l'energia elettrica viene
condotta in modo più ottimale la
condotta nhtsa cutanea di conseguenza si
alza questo è quello che succede con le
persone sviluppo tipico annusano l'odore
della paura sono contagiati da questa
emozione la loro condotta nhtsa cutanea
sale nel caso dell'autismo invece questa
cosa non si verifica
abbiamo visto che cosa succede al
comportamento dopo essere esposti agli
odori corporei abbiamo visto che cosa
succede alle risposte psico fisiologiche
ma che cosa succede nel nostro cervello
per rispondere a questa domanda ho
effettuato uno studio in collaborazione
con l'università di brigham young negli
stati uniti e abbiamo chiesto ad alcune
persone con autismo e non di portare in
laboratorio un loro familiare o un amico
stretto una persona di cui avevano avuto
l'opportunità di annusare l'odore
corporeo in questo caso abbiamo fatto
una raccolta dell'odore in modo diverso
siamo stati un pochino più cattivi
abbiamo chiesto alle persone per due
giorni di non mangiare cibi speziati non
mangiare cibi puzzolenti quindi cipolla
cruda bandita
abbiamo dato loro un preciso detergente
non potevano lavarsi con nient'altro se
non quello che noi avevamo dato a tutti
i partecipanti dello studio dopo due
giorni di cosiddetta purificazione
quello che abbiamo fatto è stato
chiedere loro di indossare una maglietta
per 12 ore consecutive tornare in
laboratorio alla fine delle 12 ore e
dopo che noi abbiamo valutato se l'odore
era stato contaminato da cibo o altre
fragranze abbiamo nuovamente tagliato la
parte che si trova sotto le ascelle e
l'abbiamo di nuovo inserite in un
contenitore di vetro
questa volta questo contenitore di vetro
veniva fatto annusare ai nostri
partecipanti che si trovavano in una
risonanza magnetica per una sessione di
risonanza magnetica funzionale ovvero
una tecnica che ci permette di vedere
come l'attività del cervello cambia in
funzione della presentazione di diversi
stimoli gli stimoli in questo caso erano
l'odore della persona familiare
l'odore di una persona non familiare al
partecipante è un odore neutro il
compito era veramente semplice annusa
l'odore dc quanto forte e quanto ti
piace
in questo caso i risultati sono stati
molto interessanti
se andiamo a vedere le risposte
esplicite alle domande quanto intenso
quanto piacevole né le persone sviluppo
tipico nelle persone con autismo
riescono a differenziare questi tre
odori ma quando andiamo a vedere le
risposte implicite che il nostro
cervello produce ecco che troviamo delle
risposte interessanti nel caso
dell'autismo e nel caso delle persone
sviluppo tipico entrambi i tipi di
cervelli riescono a differenziare
l'odore della persona familiare
dall'odore della persona non familiare
lo fanno però utilizzando computazione
che si basano su aree diverse quindi
l'autismo nell'autismo l'obiettivo
principale è cercare di capire se c'è
qualcosa di inatteso
quindi c'è una un'elaborazione primaria
delle informazioni dell'odore della
persona che non si conosce
nel caso invece delle persone sviluppo
tipico la prima distinzione a questo
d'ore proviene da una persona oppure
proviene da qualcos'altro da un oggetto
e dopo di che vado ad analizzare se
questo odore di una persona familiare
oppure non familiare quindi diciamo che
nonostante otteniamo lo stesso obiettivo
sia nell'autismo sia nel caso delle
persone a sviluppo tipico le strategie
con cui questo obiettivo viene raggiunto
sono molto diverse
se raccogliamo insieme tutte queste
informazioni relative a come le persone
con autismo elaborano le informazioni
che provengono dagli odori delle persone
possiamo parlare di diso smia sociale di
sta per distorsione osman sta per
capacità di percepire gli odori il
sociale fa riferimento al fatto che le
persone con autismo estraggono dagli
odori corporei dei segnali che sono
diversi da quelle che le persone
sviluppo tipico estraggono il se la
parola distorsione in qualche modo ci
ricorda qualcosa di negativo
vorrei ricordarvi i risultati
dell'esperimento sull'imitazione
automatica la distorsione in realtà può
portare anche a molti benefici e alla
comparsa di comportamenti funzionali se
invece c'è qualcosa che accomuna un
pochino tutti quanti neuro tipici e
persone con autismo è il fatto
che gli effetti degli odori corporei
rimangono abbastanza sommersi non
raggiungono spesso il livello della
consapevolezza non riusciamo certamente
a controllare il fatto che le mani ci
studiano di più non riusciamo a
controllare il fatto che il nostro
cervello attivi un'area piuttosto che
un'altra quindi questo tipo di
comunicazione tende a rimanere al di
sotto del livello della nostra
consapevolezza non è quindi poi così
sorprendente a questo punto solo il
fatto può essere considerato alla
stregua di cenerentola
spero però di avervi dato qualche
informazione in più rispetto a questo
senso di avervi fatto conoscere degli
aspetti non non noti e di aver suscitato
un pochino il vostro interesse
vi invito quindi a trasformare il vostro
naso nella versione più principesca di
cenerentola a fare attenzione
volontariamente ai segnali olfattivi che
vi circondano
ad apprezzare il cibo in maniera diversa
facendo attenzione all'odore a cercare i
pericoli anche attraverso l'olfatto ma
soprattutto ad apprezzare l'odore delle
persone che vi sono più care
grazie